hello everyone welcome to my virtual
talk um you might hear some background
noise from kids that will be iris and
edgar uh
who are running around the house so i
apologize for that
so i want to tell you a little bit about
open accessible cutting edge technology
for super solution machine learning
enabled microscopy
open source techniques we that we are
developing
in our research lab everything that
you're going to see
during my talk is completely open
and free you can easily apply to
research that you're using
in your lab whenever you want
everything is extremely reproducible and
accessible
so this small graph represents a little
bit some of the resources that we have
created
in our app uh in orange i am
highlighting
um the ones that i'm going to talk to
you a little bit about today as we won't
have
time to cover it up and the the reason
why i have these two friends here is
that
most of the tech that you're seeing here
is actually enabled by gpus
uh the same graphics cards you use for
computer gaming
the only thing that we're doing is we're
repurposing their capacity
for image analysis at the end and if you
follow this link you'll find
all the information that you need about
these resources
so i'll start by talking a little bit
about super solutions
which is the field that we are mostly
focused on
uh and so let me tell you a little bit
how uh singapore acquisition microscopy
and stochastic signal
good causation works so imagine the
phone imagine that you're the microscope
under microscope and you're observing
that object there
in this case it could be something like
a mitochondria right and because of the
resolution limits on
confirmation of microscopes that comes
from defections you're going to get
a board image out of it
what techniques like single molecule
microscopy try to do
is actually word information contents
that you have in an image
so on these techniques you actually
turn off the majority of fruit force
that are presented there
uh this is done by uh leveling your
example with photoshop
through four that you in a white
mediated manner you can
uh force them to transition into a dark
state
and then you wet a very small subset of
through force
come back into a fluorescent state again
it is also mediated
by light but what happens is that
because there is a reduced number of
forces that are actually now active the
information content that you have on
that image
it's much simpler it's simpler to the
point where you can actually
detect and localize with a very high
precision the small number of molecules
that are actually
now actively embedded what do you do
next
you turn off those motors turn on the
smaller another small subset detect
localize
and if you cycle through these several
images where you're activating
and deactivating molecules the
technicalizing each one of them
you'll end up having a reconstruction of
your sample
which has a much higher resolution than
what you were observing
at the beginning so these are the basis
for many techniques like palm
storm dna paint and so forth
okay so there is also a little bit of a
problem
with this because what you're relying
now on
is a large number of images with very
few molecules
present in them and if you want to
recapitulate the position of all
the modules that are presently labeled
in your sample
you might need to acquire thousands to
hundreds of thousands
uh of images
and these will take time which means
that it's also
not very compatible with lifestyle image
so this was one of the key challenges we
wanted to address which is
could we actually step away from these
uh kind of acquisitions where we need
many many images to create a
reconstruction could we do it in a short
burst
so that's the reason why we developed
surf
which i'm going to tell you a little bit
about it now
so surf it's a purely analytical super
solution
approach and what it tries to do
is it tries to grab a very small set
of images where you have through force
lightly
oscillating there in this case you're
seeing alexa 647
in 100 images acquired at about 100
frames per second so that they said
took one second to acquire and what
the surf algorithm tries to do is
actually
it will start by trying to calculate
regions of space that have a high degree
of radial symmetry why is that
interesting
it's interesting because if you have a
full force that's emits a signal that is
slightly brighter than any other signal
that exists in its vicinity
it will have a radio symmetric profile
to
the to the fact that the diffractions
that you have on your microscope will
create
uh psf's that are regularly symmetric
so if we just look for points of high
degree of radio symmetry
on these edges that you have here you'll
get something like this
right and what the algorithm is trying
to do is
it's trying to estimate where do you
have those through four that are
slightly
transiently brighter than anything in
its vicinity
now the problem is that there are also a
lot of false positives there because
even noise
in a completely random way can present a
radio symmetric profile and that's a
little bit what you see
here for example there aren't any force
there but there's a little bit of signal
happening there
now what's interesting is that um the
signal from noise
is and created in time what that means
is that as you know that you have on the
pixel
which comes from noise has very little
to do with the signal that you're going
to get on the next time point which also
comes from nice
but the signal that comes actually from
through force that are oscillating
has a tendency to be self-correlated so
if i just start
uh projecting temporal correlations on
the data that i see there
what i'm going to do is i'm going to get
back structure
which has actually a higher resolution
and dampens
down noise and represents the structure
that you'll see there
in the fraction now you have to
be a bit wary of the super social image
that you start seeing now here
because the information that you have
here while it represents the same
structure that you see on the left
uh the meaning of the signal is
completely different because the signal
that you have here on this diffraction
limited image
actually crew weighs to a large degree
with the number of row fours that you
have there
because the brightness that you have is
the number of photos that were walk away
detected
and the number of others that were
detected is somewhat proportional to the
stoichiometry
of of force that you have locally in
that region of space
the signal that you actually have on the
superstition course
image corresponds to the algorithm
capacity to find correlations on
oscillating through force
so it has a little bit of a different
meaning and therefore
it's a little bit harder to to relax
this intensity
with the stoichiometry of force you
might have on your example so keep that
in mind
now why is this interesting well for a
very dead and fixed cell
you don't really care because you can
take as much time as you want
to to image that sample so you could
actually just use conventional palm
storm
and and some of the best algorithms that
is out there to take those in visual
fruitfuls
but for a living cell when you're trying
to meet really fast and have very few
images
uh that capture those oscillations and
when you're put
much less illumination into your sample
you can do something like this
uh in this case we're we're creating a
soft reconstruction of the data that you
see there on your left
and while the the the resolution
improvement isn't as high as you would
get on a fixed cell image by palm storm
what you do get is that you can
continuously
image the sample for over 30 minutes
without any meaningful sign of either
photo bleaching or photo damage to
december
so so try to think the last time that
you saw a super social movie
that was continuously imaged for more
than two minutes there aren't that many
approaches out there that are able
to achieve this um and this is some of
the regimes where surf actually does
a really good job
all right now keep in mind that surf is
trying to
do its special best job trying to
predict what is the underlying structure
that you have
on your diffraction magnetic images uh
these means that it is also prone to
defects and we've been working quite
a bit on this uh so you see here romance
in here down and he's been working on a
new version of five surf which will
uh uh which will come out sometime in
the near future we hope
and uh it provides super social images
with considerably
higher quality than what we did with the
original stuff i've written
it's the images that are much more
linear to the first image you are going
to get
much less structural merging and the
overall quality that you get
is much higher as you can see by the
error maps that you get here for example
that are concreted with squirrel
another argument that i'm going to tell
you about in a few seconds
so do you believe me and
the correct answer should be not
completely
as i was telling you uh
surf and actually any
superstition methods which relies on the
non-linear
uh algorithm between first position
is prone to artifacts and defects
um so it's all about trying to
understand what the quality and fidelity
of the image that you get
and how much information can you
retrieve uh with
the installs um defects these can be
small or large
and and that needs to be taken into
account as you quantify
that data so we created squirrel and
algorithm that
calculates uh the quality and fidelity
of
supersocial images and let me go a
little bit
how this works and here's the paper by
the way
where you can read more about it
let's give us thought about image
formation for a second
uh so we went to a microscope apart
diffraction limits its image
and we know that what we're seeing must
represent some kind of
uh level structure that we have in our
sample
and we know a little bit about what
happens on the microscope we know that
there's diffraction and that diffraction
comes from
some of the parameters like the aperture
that you have on your
microscope so that means that the
diffraction limited image
that we get is the results of the
fractions when observing your level
structure
so what is the supersocial image
well the super solution image is your
best
guess of what that labeled structure
is and as such there must be
a resolution loss functions that if you
apply to that
super solution image it will create an
image that has a high degree of
similarity
to the diffraction limited image you
would get on the microscope
however if that super social image
contains
defects as you're seeing here when you
apply that resolution loss function
the result image that you get does have
the similarities to the diffraction
limited image you will get on
you get on the microscope so that means
that if you compare those two images the
diffraction will be the image that you
get for free when you use a normal
microscope
and the the uh the resolution was
uh image that you get from your
spreadsheet image
those similarities will get you where
you actually have errors on your data
so let me show you these being applied
here's a white field image and here's
the equivalent super solution image and
by i i would say that the superstition
image actually looks like
uh close to perfect right
um however what happens if we actually
calculate an error map
with squirrel well
what squirrel actually tells you is that
the
quality of the image is not homogeneous
throughout the field of view and there
is areas that are pretty good and
there's
areas that are a little bit problematic
which is what you see there
in bright green and if we insert some of
those areas
you see that for example most of the
problems happens
when you have filaments crossing each
other which means that the number of
molecules
that exists in that region of spacing
increases which makes it harder for the
super solutions
algorithms to disentangle individual
molecules that might exist there
so that's that's kind of okay we we were
already expecting for those
errors to potentially exist but that
also means that there's areas on
your image that are better than others
now here's another interesting thing
which is if i now break
this supersocial image into blocks and
calculate the resolution
for each individual block we're going to
see something that might be a little bit
surprising
which is resolution is actually not
homogeneous throughout the field of view
and this is a little bit
interesting and problematic with what
you read normally in publications
because in the publications you will see
uh researchers and authors telling you
a unique resolution number that they get
for that image
normally that unique resolution number
is the minimal number you would get
on a map a resolution map
like this so in this case for example i
would in that case say that this image
has 36 nanometers
but in reality that's not a full story
because again resolution is not
homogeneous because it depends on the
capacity of these algorithms
to pick up the position of roof force
that exists on your data
so not only do you need one shoes
account for
quality variation on the data you should
also account for
variation in the resolution itself
so we we as the field needs to be a
little bit better at
acknowledging uh that these things
happen and
it's all okay in terms of notifications
as long as you know exactly
what degree of confidence and resource
confidence and resources and quality
you should have regarding your data
so scroll is really useful and there's
many defects
that it can detect i'm showing you some
of them here
uh you can for example detect structural
merging
uh non-wear linearity in fractures
aggregates uh uh and the typical
problems you might find in your tech
okay so i told you about surf uh
purely analytical superstition methods
that can actually be applied to most
uh for instance microscopes i'll talk to
you all about squirrel and algorithm
that
is able to pick up uh the quality that
you get on and resolution that you get
on those images
uh and this has been a little bit
focused for lifestyle imaging where
uh you are kind of trying your best to
not damage your cells with likes which
constraints
with what you can do in terms of imaging
but there's so much more you can do
in a fixed cell because on the fix so it
can take as much time
to to analyze that cell as you want
so so we're wondering about this how can
we take the best
of both worlds image example that is
both alive
and that well that's impossible
what you can do is you can actually
image the transition between
both and our way to do that is actually
through microphotics
as i told you we like to do everything
open source and
accessible to everyone so we actually
used lego to do it
so so uh you have the picture of
christopher
here who has been our major cooperator
once
what you're seeing and we i think we did
something very interesting with
this project with him okay so you're
seeing here pumpy which is a strange
bumper right
uh fully controlled by the microscope uh
which is
really inexpensive and it can be built
in lego which means that the 14 year old
kid can actually build it if he
or she wants to so
here's the papers in case you want to
follow it up
so what can you do with it um well the
first thing that we
we showcased is that you can do live to
fix imaging right
so in this case for example i'm going to
show you a movie
and here we're just doing high wall on
this sample and
we're going to switch into surf mode
which allows us to get a little bit of
resource enhancement
and we then trigger the microphotic
system
pumpy to automatically fix
and label the sample which allows us
without moving stuff out of the
microscope
to then directly collect a storm dataset
which will take
minutes to to acquire but what we have
now is
a a dataset which has a temporal history
of
lifestyle behavior uh with limited
resolution coming from surf
which upon fixations allows us to get
much higher resolution
on what we see and now because we
actually have a fixed sample what we can
actually do
is uh web form one through four and with
the syringe
pump array we can actually use uh
techniques like complete photobreaching
of that fro4 allowing us to re-label the
sample for
two other proteins which we're doing
here and then applying the
nail paint and then strip out that label
for other proteins
super resolve it and the nice thing is
that this is actually theoretically
unlimited on the number of different
proteins we can
image so although i'm sure casing here
five i could pretty much do small scale
proteomics on the sample
while having the benefit of actually
having the temporal history of its
behavior
up to a certain time point
so the nice thing is that since it's
lego there's many people that already
reproduce the system out there and i
essentials
that is making a few apps quite happy
okay so i told you about a little bit of
software that we've created
hard where it's bumpy what about probes
um so we wanted to see if we could
create
uh probes that were very much within the
ethos of open source
and and here's what we've come up with
and we call them super beacons i'll tell
you a little bit about how super
weekend's
work here here's the paper in case you
want to follow up
on mascara
so super beacons are actually based on
marker beacons
micro beacons are just a dna strands
where you have
uh on this ends um a stem parts that
self hybridizes
and makes these kind of airplanes the
interesting thing
is you can melt that stem
which will make the the the the
five primary prime ends which in this
case is created by a fruit four
and a quantity they will be able to get
away from each other
so when you have airplane configuration
the quencher is in contact with the
fruit floor
uh which will almost completely quench
the francis that you have there so also
the probe is dark
and when the probe opens up you actually
have the quantity away from the profile
which will allow for to emit fight
so these probes were originally created
as
sensors for oligonucleotides but what
we've done
is that we've tried to make whoop parts
that
hybridize almost with nothing on the
cell
and with that what we just do is we
redesign a little bit of structure
in a way so that at room temperature you
have
a probe that is unstable so it's
constantly switching between
an open set and a cool state so what it
means is that
if we now bind this probe to something
like a dna
uh something like an antibody a methy
body
um you will see
the pro poinking which is what you're
seeing here
so in practice we have a mechanical way
to induce photo switching now and
this mechanical way is fairly
insensitive
to to the illumination intensity that
you put in so for example you could
expect
uh similar photo stitching kinetics
independently
of the microscope that you're using it
also means that i can use variable
illuminations to get stem to to
photo switch which makes them actually
quite appealing for a white cell image
and here i'm just showing you what
happens to these three probes here
uh on steep movie what you're seeing is
that uh at a certain stage
now i'm adding formamides to to
the environments that's uh where the
problems are and
formamide will actually induce the
probes to mostly be
on an open state so that means that you
see the majority of probes that
are actually decorated with the
coverslip before we
actually ask the from wide you just see
the probes pointing on and off
so we started using them for for imaging
which is what you see
here hold on there's my daughter here
okay i am in the middle of a talk now it
is put your minds
if we talk another time yeah okay
so i need to finish the talk okay
it is come on i need to to finish this
can you go
no i don't need it you can take it with
you
i'll catch you in 15 minutes maybe okay
see you later come on close the door
sorry for the interruption
okay so how can you use these probes
um one of the things that we've done is
we created
a site in the middle of props with
biotin
which means that if you have antibodies
with streptavidin
you can actually decorate those
antibiotics with the pros we use
this for example to image ifdm3 which
you're seeing here
where on the right you already see the
super social image
that you can get with disabilities
the interesting thing is that these
props are pretty much
primers you can just order them and and
directly buy them against antibodies if
you want to
they're super easy to get access to to
access
and to use all right
so let's go to the last part which is
zero cost
deep warning for microscopy and here's
the paper in case you want to read it
on this part i also wanted to
particularly acknowledge that the
checkmate laboratory who has been there
at
a full time helping us
build this up and this project is really
a 50 50
contribution from both swaps with the
help of many other
cooperators also that you see named here
so let's talk a little bit about how one
can use deep learning in microscopy
so generally when you use some kind of
image analysis
algorithm that is not machine learning
already learning
based you you start with some kind of
input
image you apply that algorithm which has
a known routine
which gives you some kinds of results as
you see here
and just to give you an example this
could be for example
a noisy image and the algorithm would
denoise
the image based on some prior knowledge
that developers and that you as user
given
the algorithm which gets you a noise
image
so what machine learning algorithms
generally do is instead of having
known routines which is already
established what you actually do
is you fit the algorithm pairs of images
uh one being the the the
type of images which will be used as an
input and one being the type of
resulting image that you want in this
case what i could actually do
is show the algorithm multiple images
of how a noisy image looks like and the
equivalent non-noisy image
these could be missed quick going to the
microscope and acquire uh two images
with defense exposure times or
illumination intensities and it's very
easy to get these kind of pairs
but what i'm going to do is i'm going to
show a few tens to hundreds of these
images to the
machine learning algorithm and the
algorithm will actually
try to learn an internal model which
maps
one type of image with the one on the
left into the image on the right
and once the algorithm actually learns
this model
what i can do is i can show
now uh an input image
and the algorithm will predict how the
equivalent
pair image would look like so in this
case
without knowing much about the noise of
the image itself but quieting the images
are noisy and noisy i can actually get a
machine learning everything that learns
how to noise it great there's a lot we
can do
with this the the major thing you have
to
however now understand is that there are
two stages to
these kind of algorithms there is a
training stage
where you show many many images an
algorithm tries to understand
how to create a model that maps one type
of image to another type of image
and once it's more in this model you can
go to another stage which is prediction
where
the algorithm doesn't need to learn
anymore the only thing that you do is
you give it an input image
and then it predicts what would be the
equivalent paired image
training takes a lot of resources and
it's really hard
the reason why this is is because the
algorithm is trying to find its internal
structure to actually understand how to
do this pairing
and inference it's much easier because
the algorithm already learned this it's
only applying
whatever it's already learned into a new
image and giving you the prediction
okay so to give you a sense this for
example is a training set
uh that we use uh for for example the
noising
and to really show you that's that's you
need quite a
lot of images to train these kind of
algorithms
okay i gave you the noisy example uh but
there are
many types of machine learning
algorithms out there
and the majority of them follow these
kind of paired image rules right
where you show pairs of images and it
learns some kind of model
that will translate one type of image to
the other
however it is not really very accessible
to mulch
to most researchers because you need
dedicated computational resources really
powerful gpus to do these kind of
calculations
and you also need a little bit about
knowledge about how to set these neural
networks up
and this is the saying that we've tried
to tackle with zero cost department for
microscopy
here what we actually are doing is we're
using
free resources provided by google to
make
deep learning much more accessible to
researchers that
are not necessarily experts in any way
in machine learning so here's how it is
done
you need a computer almost any type of
computer
as long as it is a browser what you're
going to be able to do
is with the browser you need to be able
to uh
to transfer into google drive
some training data and some data you
wanna analyze
uh don't forget uh you get actually free
storage with google drive now once you
have your data in google drive you can
actually open
some of our google co-op notebooks and
what these google cloud notebooks
are is that they they pretty much
provide you a graphics interface
that is extremely self-explanatory and
simple to use
you need no coding skills to actually
run them
and these notebooks will actually run on
a service given by google called google
co-app
pretty much google gives you access to a
free gpu
to write your data on it all done in the
cloud right the only thing that you
have is data that you need to transfer
and the computer with the browser
so the the first thing that's uh uh our
notebooks allows you to do is to train
the neural networks
to to be able to to infer data based on
the type of data that you're going to
give the algorithms
once training is done you can actually
start predicting
some of the results that you want to get
and i'm going to show you some of kind
of predictions that you can't do
with uh with zero quality learning for
microscopy
and once you have a train network and
you start feeding it data
you can pull results from from
the calls back into your computer
now what's interesting about this uh
zero costs depending on microscope
pretty much provide you
free code based access to gpus using
google app
it has a simple user interface which
means you don't need no coding
it's really meant for cell biologists to
use
the system and it's a single platform
for training prediction and
quality control and i'm going to
emphasize quality control here
because we took quite a bit of time to
make sure that you had
quality control measurements in place to
guarantee
that you could assess how good the data
is that you're getting out of those
networks
okay so we've pretty much implemented
some of the most popular neural networks
that exist out there these have been
developed by
other webs we've pretty much
made an interface for them and optimize
them to use google chrome
and all of this is exposed on our wiki
you can just go there
almost press single buttons the opening
collab
we also provide example data sets which
you see there on the bottom
and it's easy for you to learn how to
use uh
neural networks using these interfaces
and start using your own
data so to give you a few examples of
uh you can do with this these are some
of the tasks we've implemented i'm just
going to run this because it's a movie
so the first task you're going to see
is segmentations for this for example
you have units
units can grab either phrases or young
images to segment them
we've implemented a star test so this
was designed
to to optimally detect cell node quizzes
labeled for example with typing
you can do denoising and in this case
you're seeing
noise to voice running
you can also use care for image
restoration
care is definitely one of the most
popular algorithms
uh out there and you can run many
different tasks from inside from
restoration
and you can do label prediction in this
case the neuranonex was
trying to look at a bright field image
and predict what would be the equivalent
fluorescence image
and there's many people that have
already tried it uh
check out the hashtag zero cross
departing for microscopy on twitter
and you can find some very nice examples
of other webs
running the network on their own data
and getting some results
out of it i think it's being
considerably useful to the community
all right and that's i'm getting to the
end of my talk
and the last thing i wanted to do is if
you're someone looking for a postdoc
come join our web we are moving from ucl
to ancient greece
in portugal and we have now positions
open so
consider applying and with that i wanted
to acknowledge
the web plus some of our funding sources
and many of the groups that have helped
us get there
i biologize if not all of them are
mentioned them
there you can also see full lists on our
webpage of our co-writers
thank you for listening and i'm happy to
take any questions you might
have if not after this virtual talk
by email